enjoy your life fibre-to-the-home brings  people together download and upload at  the speed of light blu-ray in 33 minutes  DVD in six minutes 300 photos in 58  seconds real-time interactivity stay  connected  drive innovation fibre-to-the-home  empowers a new realm of services content  and applications remote century  remote care intelligent power grid  intelligent network high security  network systems personal TV video on  demand  cloud computing  online gaming video conferencing  elearning  this your business communicates faster  more effectively and with better quality  avoid traffic  work from home  and reach the world  go sustainable with fiber to the home  tomorrow is now fibre-to-the-home  Council Europe creating a brighter  future